you remember anything about the vehicle
what can you tell us about him
he smoked winston's
hey guys pete here the mayor of east
town trailers have been pretty revealing
over the past couple of weeks
surely there's some misdirection going
on but they're giving us a glimpse of
some pretty important looking scenes
the one after the last episode episode 4
also feels like it might be hinting at a
grim
fate for one of the main characters so
today i'm gonna break it down scene by
scene
after that i'll get into some of my
theories about how i think mayor of east
town will end
and talk about some of the other popular
ones that are out there
before we get started this trailer says
in the weeks ahead
the one last week said next on and all
those scenes were in the previous
episode but these are more likely a
collection of shots from the final three
episodes
since we're looking at a trailer there's
going to be things from future episodes
that could include spoilers if you don't
like that sort of thing
so this is your chance to leave the
title of episode 5 is illusions and the
synopsis says
in her mandated therapy mayor opens up
about her family's history with mental
health struggles
meanwhile laurie tries to get to the
bottom of her son's outburst at school
and later mayor meets with a
semi-retired source
to help find a possible connection to
her three cases
and the first shot is of mare talking to
a new character in a diner
it seems likely that this is the
semi-retired source
since she seems to have access to sex
workers
mayor tells her about the girls going
missing before she asks her to ask
around about anything suspicious
especially
someone suspicious trying to pick up
girls and we will come back to her
because she shows up again later in the
trailer
as they're talking there are a couple of
shots of aaron's bike being pulled out
of the water
it looks like someone found it and now
the police are collecting it as
evidence then there are two shots that
involve richard
and the first one mares at home with her
arm bandaged up
and he visits with a gift basket with
what looks like
scrumptious hoagies inside she looks
happy to see him as does helen who's
smiling ear to ear in the background of
the shot
then we see them kiss somewhere
different as her hair's down and they're
in different clothes
and in voiceover as they kiss we hear
colin's mother saying that she knows he
likes her because of the way he looks at
her
that conversation is happening over
coffee at their house
that cuts to colin and mayor having
dinner in a restaurant
mayor wasn't sure who she was going to
go out with on saturday night and this
makes it look
like she picked colin her arm isn't in
the bandage yet while they're at dinner
and this makes me think this is her
taking him up on that offer of a date
from what they're saying it doesn't
sound like it's going well though
she says i'm trying to help you out here
and he fires back
help me or help yourself it's pretty
hard to speculate what they're arguing
about here
but what we know is that she's been put
on leave while he's still working the
case
he obviously likes her and wants to get
together
and i was under the impression she was
feeling something too before i saw this
after that we see deacon mark come into
a pizza shop there's a group of locals
sitting at the table and one of them
tells the other
hey that's that priest i was telling you
about the group followed him outside
with the guys yelling at him calling him
a pedophile
and it looks like they beat him up or
chase him away at the very least
this might be related to the reporter
calling father dan
either way it looks like the story about
mark's past is getting out there and
more people are finding out about it
which seems pretty bad for him
in this small community at the diner we
see colin and mayor asking a different
girl
who's with the woman from the beginning
of the trailer what can you tell us
about the vehicle and what can you tell
us about him
this is definitely a different girl it's
not katie and it's not missy
and it sounds like she had a run in with
the same man who kidnapped those two
there's not much in the trailer about
how she met him or how she got away
or anything along those lines but she is
able to say
that she remembered him smoking winstons
it's been a while since i've been in
pennsylvania
or the us at all for that matter but
winston's weren't very popular the last
time i was there
that makes this seem like a pretty
valuable clue in the next sequence when
we see colin notice a pack and point it
out to mare
it seems like that was the intention
because right after that he makes a move
to the gun in his shoulder holster
now we don't know what episode this will
happen in but it does look like it's a
rundown apartment
and it is connected to the last couple
of shots i'm gonna talk about
we hear mare tell her therapist i can
feel it happening again like
panic like this expectation of people to
be something i don't think i'm good
enough to be
there's a shot of lori walking her into
her house with helen there waiting at
the door
there's reporters and cameras they're
all waiting outside for her when she
gets there
then we see mare walking into a body of
water it looks like she's chasing
someone or going after something
i would guess this comes from the end of
the series and is related to aaron's
killer
but i'll have to come back to that
because this is just one quick shot
after that we see helen embrace mayor
who's crying
at first i thought this was when she
came into the house past the reporters
but if you look closely it's dark
outside here
and there doesn't appear to be anyone
outside the window
there's a struggle between mare and
siobhan in her room
she looks upset and her mother is sort
of holding her wrist to kind of control
her
it cuts to a different shot of siobhan
where she says
maybe you could be my mom for a second
there's a quick shot of mare running
into a house
and i saw on reddit that a couple people
pointed out that this is actually betty
carroll's place
no idea why she's there right now but it
might mean that we'll get a payoff to
the peeping tom story
or there's something that's going to
come up because of mayors deleting that
security footage
then there's this shot of billy ross
putting a pack of what looks like
fishing bobbers into a tackle box on the
bed of his truck
when we see inside we get a glimpse of a
gun and he looks pretty nervous
all the way around billy has been high
on my list of suspects and that does
make this pretty exciting to see
but because it's so short and just so
crazy that he has a gun because he's a
side character for the most part
the shot reminds me of the fake out in
the last trailer a little
where dylan was walking up to dj's crib
with the pillow
so i will come back to that that cuts to
a conversation between lori and mare
with lori saying i didn't know when you
asked me before
i swear i didn't know and there's
another shot of lori by herself
she's looking at something with a tear
rolling down her cheek
the episode description said that
laurie's going to be trying to figure
out what's going on with her son
but this could also be related to her
husband which is high on a lot of
people's suspects list
and her saying i didn't know when you
asked me before
i'm not really sure what she's referring
to there then we see jess hand the chief
what looks like a photograph
we just see him look at it there's no
indication of what's on it or why she's
there
this is followed up by dylan leaning out
of his friend's car window
asking jess what she told that detective
this is interesting because mare and
colin are the detectives that we know
not sure if he's asking about when they
visited her or what the chief thing
seems to be something different though
dylan adds that the three of us are
joined together forever
and he screams at her to get in the car
she gets scared and runs away and then
later we see her being pulled out from a
hiding place underneath a different car
this was kind of a shock because jess
was presented as an honest character who
cared about her good friend aaron
while dylan was the exact opposite
there's no natural connection for these
two
the kid driving the car is someone we've
seen a couple of times
he filmed the fight in the woods he was
interviewed by the police and talked
about brianna
and dylan says the three of us so does
he mean this
kid as number three so the last two
shots that i haven't talked about
first we see this shot of mare this was
in the original trailer this is
something we've seen before
she's got a gun in her hand she's in the
rundown looking house
in front of the store which we clearly
see earlier in the trailer when colin
points out the winston there's several
things going on
in this shot for one mayer has a gun
when the chief came to her house to put
her on administrative leave
she turned in her badge and her gun her
other hand
is bloody now this is the hand that
we'll see bandaged up
later so that makes me think that she
gets injured in whatever's going on here
since it's in the same place where they
saw the winstons
that makes you think they found their
way to the kidnapper's house
when we see outside it doesn't look the
same as what we saw
whenever they went into that benny's
tavern location where the girls are
hidden
i'm not really sure what to say about
that but unless
this is a total misdirection it looks
like they found their suspect
the final scene to talk about though is
this scene
of mare hitting someone over the head in
what looks like it could be where the
girls were hidden you can't make out
much in this shot but there are some
similarities to the room we saw them
being held in
you can't make out for sure who this guy
is even when i look at it frame by frame
and lighten it up
it just looks the same as the shot of
the person in the van
i do think this is the kidnapper my
thoughts on him have been that
it's someone we haven't met yet and i
don't see anything in this trailer that
would change my opinion on that
and since that was the last image i
wanted to talk about
now i'll tell you what i think is going
on and how the series might end
going into episode 4 i was already
starting to think that aaron's and
katie's cases weren't connected
their backgrounds and lifestyles were
just so different we did learn that
aaron has some secrets and there might
be more there
but after we saw misty's abduction i
felt pretty confident that this was
something separate from what happened to
aaron
after seeing the trailer i'm further
convinced and as i
said this guy just seems like some
random criminal who abducts girls and
uses them as his sex slaves
at least for right now i don't think
he's connected to anything else that's
going on in the story
i've seen people who are looking closely
at the images saying that they think
it's father dan
or dylan's dad or even some are still
holding on to the idea that it might be
deacon mark but i don't think it'll turn
out to be any of those people
plus considering mare's injury and her
bandages and shots that come after this
one where she has the gun
i think this will get solved before the
final episode and not turn out to be the
big revelation
the bandages are sort of really throwing
me off though
because this seems like it would be the
penultimate episode cliffhanger
but i guess it's possible this might go
down next week because there's clearly a
lot of stuff that happens with mare
after she gets her injury either way
they can tie this up
they can find out what happened to katie
and missy and that leaves time to show
the aftermath
as these stories usually do they focus
our attention on the crime they focus
our attention on the mystery trying to
solve it
and by the end we realize it's a
character study and the journey of the
main character
as they are dealing with these cases
here we have the added layer of aaron's
murder
and this small town where everyone's
connected and everyone has secrets
after the red herrings don't pan out the
real suspect emerges
and it's usually someone who's been
hanging around that's sort of been there
in the background
that we haven't had a strong reason to
suspect but it will make sense when we
go back and look at it later
this is why i've been so focused on all
those weird shots where the camera
lingers on different characters billy
ross has been number one on my suspect
list
i've been sure he's been up to something
and i guess it's going to come down to
whether he's just the father of aaron's
child
or if he's her murderer or i guess he
could actually be both
that's why the trailer really throws
things for a loop because showing him
with a gun makes him look pretty guilty
and it almost makes it too convenient it
makes me wonder if he's just
involved with her like he had a secret
relationship with her
possibly he's dj's father that's
definitely something he wouldn't want to
get out there
but then we also have this connection
with what laurie's saying in the trailer
which seems to indicate that something's
going on with her
son and possibly her husband because her
son had one of those scenes in the last
episode where we were supposed to kind
of wonder what's going on with him
i think maybe he's going to discover
something rather than he actually did
something i mean he's a kid
and considering that laurie looks upset
and that she's telling mare
something that she didn't know before
i'm gonna guess that he found out
something
related to his dad or his uncle or both
of them together
but that's really as far as i can go
with that as far as deacon mark's
concerned
it looks like his story is gonna get out
there that's gonna be bad for him
they're gonna discover the bike which
might also be a problem
i still think he's one of the red
herrings he had a connection with aaron
she did call him
and maybe there's more to it considering
he did have her bike in his car
but his story feels more like a
distraction from what's really going on
based on when they introduced him as a
suspect
there's a chance that he actually told
colin and mayor the truth when they
interviewed him at the church
but even if he doesn't have any big
secret here it looks like he's going to
run into some issues before
all is said and done for jess and dylan
i'm really not sure what's going on
there
in the last episode jess sorta came on
the radar
after she misled mare about where the
journals were
mostly because of the shot they showed
where she was watching them leave
through her window
it looked like she hadn't told them the
whole story from there you have to
wonder if her accusing
frank of being dj's father might have
also been under false pretenses
but it's all pretty vague at this point
and from what we've seen there's really
been no indication that she was
connected to dylan
i'll make another video next week to
re-evaluate because i'm really not sure
what to make of mare's story
it's clear that we're supposed to like
her and root for her and want to see her
have this
big change or something along those
lines but there's still this huge issue
with her planning the heroin on carrie
a cop planning evidence like that is
just not
something that you can sweep under the
rug in my mind there has to be something
to follow that
if this is supposed to be a story about
her coming to terms with her situation
i mean it could have just been a really
bad writing choice which will undermine
the overall project but i'd like to
think that's not the case
i'm still holding out hope that there's
something i'm not seeing
the big glaring thing that comes to mind
after looking at this trailer
closely is that shot with mare and her
back against the door
with the bleeding hand and the gun what
is going on there
like i said this is definitely the same
house where colin went for his gun in
the holster mare shouldn't have a gun on
her
and that's got to make you wonder if
it's his
in the follow-up scene where she's
hitting who i think is the kidnapper
colin isn't there he doesn't seem to be
around and at that point she isn't
trying to shoot anyone
so in front of the door does she have
his gun and if she does does that mean
that colin got killed
i'm not a hundred percent sold on that
but it would make for a hell of an
aftermath after she catches the
kidnapper one theory that's out there
that i haven't been a big fan of was
that colin had something to do with the
kidnappings or with aaron
the nice guy the by the book cop it's
all just a cover story and he's really
up to no good
i still don't love this but if you're so
inclined
then it's possible she found out while
they were in that house
and that could make for a situation
where she ends up shooting him herself
i think it's more likely that he gets
shot inside the house and survives
she's able to get a hold of his gun and
stop the kidnapper maybe even kill him
and then that sets up an interesting
situation she wasn't supposed to be
there or anywhere near the case in the
first place
and now she's in a tough spot because we
see that patrol cars do roll up outside
and they're gonna know that she was
there and she was still working the case
we'll see though maybe this week maybe
next
overall that's where i'm at i think
we'll see the kidnapper turn out to be
doing his own thing
unconnected to aaron's case there we'll
see someone who's been around the story
like billy or john ross turn out to be
the key to solving that
dylan and jess might know something
about it or they might have a darker
secret
but i don't think we know enough about
their connection to make a good guess at
this point at least i don't have a good
guess at this point
i know richard being the killer is a
thing that's been around since the
beginning
i sort of put him in the red herring
category 2 but i see where people are
coming from thinking he might be
involved
there's also the theory that he's
getting close to mare because he's
writing a book
and there might be something to that we
see them kissing the trailer
so he's not going to fade into the
background even if she does wind up
going for calling in this love triangle
thing that we have going on
and it goes without saying that you
don't hire this guy unless he has some
important role to play in the story
i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know what you think is
going to happen
in the comments please like this video
if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already i'll be doing two mayor
of east town videos a week from here on
out until the series ends
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon